[Music]
hey sam how are you
hey dave hey dave how you doing today
good you sound a lot better now how can
i help
okay uh so
uh i'm in baby step number two i have my
thousand dollar emergency fund
uh my car my car was my first debt to
pay off on a debt snowball i had like
800 left on that so i paid that off um
early
and um
i also have other loans so i have a two
thousand dollar loan i have a uh eight
thousand dollar loan
uh nine thousand dollar loan and an
eleven thousand dollar loan
um
the eleven thousand dollar loan that i
have is with the same bank that uh i
took my car loan out from
and uh since i paid off my car early i
wanted to get my title from the bank
and because i have a
defaulted loan
uh with the same bank
uh there they won't release my title
they're saying it's cross-collateral
for that loan yep
and uh the debt recovery department for
that bank contacted me
and there
i guess they wanted a lump sum
for the loan
and i don't have that money right now so
they're uh what did they offer you
what did they offer you on the loan
uh he didn't offer a lower amount he
just said i thought i could get the if i
could pay the 11 grand i asked him if i
could maybe make payments on it
um but he said now
uh we would have to go to court and um
he's threatening to sue me for the 11
grand
so i have no idea what to do i'm not
sure if how long has it been done you
paid so how long has it been since
you've been three years it's been three
years since i paid that loan
[Music]
what's your car so uh i
my car is worth 7 500. the thing is i'm
a full-time uber driver so i need my car
i wasn't saying that
i'm just trying to figure out what's
going on all right
so um okay so
uh what are you making what kind of
what's your
i make income 4 000 a month
that's good
okay yes
all right um so the 11 000 was later on
in the debt snowball that's why i wasn't
planning on paying it now i was going to
take care of the next loan that was in
line yeah after my car what you've run
into here is what's called a drag net
clause
standard
uh loan documents with the typical
commercial bank
allows them if you have a loan and it's
in default to cross-collateralize and
hold your collateral
i ran into that with commercial paper it
wasn't a car loan deal but it was
something else when i was going broke i
thought i had cleared this property and
i thought i was going to be able to move
it and take care of something else and i
go in the bank's like oh no we're going
to keep that deed thank you very much
and i ran into the exact same thing and
it's pretty much an emotional gut punch
because you think you're making progress
and then they take you out so what's the
name of this yeah
uh it's the hawaii state federal credit
union okay which is the name you need to
remember the rest of your life that
keeps you so pissed off you never borrow
money again because you now know what it
feels like i'm never crude
right i'm never boring any money from
them ever again this is just or anybody
ever
because of the way they remember
yeah mine was called sun trust
okay so just to give you an idea but
anyway the um
you just remember for 30 years you're
still pissed off you know i mean i'm
never borrowing money again because the
way these
people
treat you
um so
uh
you need to scrape up some money really
fast and make them a lump sum offer like
five grand for this eleven and see if
you can discount and pay it off
okay stop everything and pile up cash
and make them a lump sum offer
okay would it be wise to um
possibly take out
a loan for the 12 grand and pay them
that and pay be wise to take out a loan
for seven grand and settle this settle
the 11.
okay because you already have an 11 000
loan if at the end of this conversation
you have a seven thousand dollar loan we
made progress
okay i'm not telling you to borrow money
i'm telling you to move some of your
debt
and make it more efficient
yeah so you haven't paid on the thing in
three years the car's not worth seven on
a repo lot it's not worth three they
don't want your car it's an emotional
play they've got on you
okay they don't really want a three
thousand dollar car because that's what
it'll bring on repo lot if it's a seven
thousand dollar car it's not gonna bring
anything
so
they're not they're not gonna come out
of this in a good shape so call them a
call if you can get a loan get that
lined up and offer them five and settle
at seven and get it in writing that
that's a settlement in full
uh-huh
and um what if i do that and they're not
willing to take the seven
they will you're just gonna have to mess
with them a while
you just got to be hardcore
because it's been three years
where have they been they weren't all
like hoppy and excited to go to a
lawsuit
two years ago
why not right you know
it's just because you activated it when
you called one your title and they went
oh we got this guy
we got this guy by the nap we're going
to shake him a little bit
and that's what he feels like happening
oh it's exactly what happened
the borrower slave to the lender and you
are experiencing that i did too i
remember this feeling it makes me mad
just hearing about it again
it's a it gets you fired up doesn't it
oh yeah i mean it sounds like they've
got some leverage on you and i want you
to take some control back so be in in
communication with them and say hey
here's what i can do take it or leave it
i haven't paid this thing in three years
you could have seven grand today how's
that sound and i think they're gonna go
okay we'll take it they may not in the
first conversation they may they may
mess with you a little bit just go
listen when you decide you want some
money you call me in the meantime i'm
going to be sitting over here
waiting for your call
and hang up hang up the phone
okay you know
i would imagine he's being rude isn't he
yeah and he's not gonna take he seems
like he's not gonna take anything but
the twelves but
that's his great job don't believe that
crap
it's just a job to him it's not his
money yeah it's been really stressing me
out yesterday and by the way listen
his job is to put a check mark in the
box beside your name that's it
and he can't put a check mark in the box
beside your name until he gets some
money from you
so you got leverage over him he needs
the check mark
okay dude get some swagger right here
get some swagger back up
yeah this guy's you ever heard the
phrase gotcha buffaloed
ever heard of that phrase no he's got
you scared
it means he's got you scared he's got
you cornered he's got you thinking he's
got you whipped and he hasn't got you
whipped he's just a duber in a cubicle
making phone calls and he needs a check
mark he works at a bank at one of the
worst jobs in the bank
it's a better job to clean septic tanks
than what he's doing
don't let him put you in the corner dude
throw your shoulders back step back up
into it punch him once and then hang up
the phone call me when you grow a brain
bozo hang up that's what you do
mess with them because that's their job
it's just a job it's not even a good job